-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden is reportedly
considering raising tariffs
on some Chinese goods.
Biden came up with the idea
the moment he realized
his fingers were stuck.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it's our last show
of the year,
so let's take a minute
to look back
on all the best moments
of 2023.
-Rudy Giuliani
to pay $148 million.
-Rudy Giuliani, $148 million.
-$148 million.
$148 million.
-What a year.
[ Laughter ]
Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis yesterday
criticized the biblical city
of Bethlehem
and said it was
a "pigsty and disgrace."
Even worse,
he did it while caroling.
[ Laughter ]
A federal judge ruled yesterday
that the two Georgia
election workers who won
a $148 million defamation
judgment against Rudy Giuliani
may expedite their payout
because they have good cause
that Giuliani might try
to avoid paying them.
How did they come
to that conclusion?
Did they look
at any picture of him?
He definitely looks like a guy
who carries a quarter
on a string
so he can use payphones
for free.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Georgia
are looking for a woman
who allegedly posed
as a Waffle House employee,
worked at the restaurant
for two hours,
and then stole cash
from the register.
A spokesman for Waffle House
is calling her
employee of the month.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
Tesla drivers have
the highest accident rate.
In fact, one of them
accidentally crashed
an entire social media site.
[ Laughter ]
The FAA said that it expects
holiday air travel
will peak today.
Okay, but what
do they mean "expect"?
We all bought our tickets
a long time ago.
You could just check.
Is anybody showing up
to the airport
on December 21st on a whim?
"Yeah, you know,
I just came out here
to have dinner at Chili's,
and then, you know,
I thought, hell, maybe I'll fly
to Orlando, you know?
Everybody else
seems to be doing it."
[ Laughter ]
A city in California held
a contest to name its snow plow,
and the winning name
was "The Big Leplowski."
As opposed to Boston,
who went with
"I Plowed Ya Mutha."
[ Laughter and applause ]
CNN published a list this week
of the worst-behaved tourists
of 2023,
but I don't even need to read it
to know what was number one,
because I'm living it
every single day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People work here!
People of business
are doing business!
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the billionaire
heir
to the luxury goods company
Hermès
has reportedly filed
to legally adopt
his middle-aged gardener
and leave him half
of his $13 billion fortune.
And I think we actually have
a photo of the gardener.
George!
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue, everybody.
We're off and running.
Off and running.